okay hello everyone welcome to another
Science and Technology q a for kids and
others and I said I would talk today
about the topic of AI
which is uh something that is being
broadly discussed these days
and uh in fact just last week we uh
introduced this plugin for chat GPT that
connects to wolfen Alpha and wolfen
language
to kind of let chat gbt really do
computation and computational knowledge
in addition to uh just doing kind of
linguistic textual types of things
let's see I see various questions that
were saved up here
there's a comment here from Miss Steven
um about chat gbt and it says uh that
comments that um apt is trained from
sort of the vast mass of what's on the
internet a few billion pages of what's
on the internet a few million books
and that that's kind of the it's trained
from the average of humanity and the
question is if one trained uh from sort
of some very selected set of great books
of humanity let's say what Mom would get
about a result
well in the current state of the art the
answer is no because it turns out that
it seems to need almost the trillion
words that it's been given
for the
for the system to get to understand sort
of the statistics of language well
enough to produce decent amounts of uh
of of text so for example if you trained
on only one hundredth of that amount of
material and that's what was done in
earlier models
it just had never seen texts that would
talk about I don't know what um uh Pink
Elephants or something and so if ever
that concept came up it's like it it's
not got any ability to to generate text
around that because just had never seen
it in a training data also it seems to
be the case that
from seeing all of that training data
it's kind of trying to understand the
regularities that exist in English the
fact that in English we have you know
sentences that have subjects and verbs
and objects and things like this and it
seems to take an awful lot of samples to
be able to learn these kind of
structural facts about uh something
something like English
um I think that when it comes to sort of
the structural facts it's learning it's
not just purely the syntactic grammar
that we're kind of used to of nouns and
verbs and parts of speech and where they
go it's also something that's more of a
meaning-based semantic grammar of you
know elephants can walk to places but
they can't fly to places those kinds of
things
so uh it's it's something where you just
need a vast mass of material a vast mass
of kind of human written material to be
able to get something which can
successfully produce text in the way
that Chachi BT does
now whether that's something that's
really intrinsic to what's going on or
whether one could instead if one knew
what to write in the kind of semantic
grammar book just like we roughly know
what to write in a syntactic grammar
book if we knew the content of a
semantic grammar book and could sort of
feed that in as computational input to
the system then one could probably deal
with a lot less training data and then
it might become more realistic to kind
of weight the thing with kind of the uh
the great books what everyone picks the
great books to be
um and have those be the things that are
the primary things that it's picking out
now it's certainly already true that you
can say uh you know write this in the
style of so and so and it will take its
its sort of foundational knowledge of
language and kind of look at it through
the lens of that particular uh
particular author and so on but it is
also true true that the general sort of
essays that GPT writes are kind of the
in some sense the average essays of
humanity so to speak it's kind of
because it's taking sort of the whole
content of the web all these books and
so on it's it's kind of averaging out
what uh what it's not taking a very kind
of uh uh it's it's taking sort of the
average point of view on things in a
first approximation you can kind of say
well sort of weight it to be more in the
style of so and so
um and uh you know the extent to which
that's successful is is unclear but sort
of the core foundational part is kind of
um from from everybody so to speak
kind of makes one wonder you know I see
there are a number of questions here
about AI alignment so just to explain
what that means it's kind of the
question is we've got these AIS they're
they're kind of running all these
systems in the world and how do we make
the AIS do things that are kind of
aligned with what we want
um how do we make sure you know the AIS
in principle could be running I don't
know some system that's well even as
they do right now you know deciding what
uh what posts to put up on our social
media feeds or or things like that or
the AIS could be doing all kinds of
things of of uh perhaps in the future of
doing sort of educational tutoring all
those kinds of things or
deciding things about actual devices
whether they're self-driving cars
whether they're other kinds of things
the question is how do we get it so that
the AIS are basically doing what we
humans think they should be doing so to
speak how do we get them to be aligned
with our kind of views about how the
world should work
now the tricky thing there is that one
one thing one might imagine doing is
just say well have the AIS watch what
humans actually do have them watch all
the movies have them read all the books
just say let's just do what humans do
problem is most people think that that's
not really a great way to act they're
things that humans aspire to doing it's
like I want to be a human who I don't
know treats everybody equally who who
you know is is always looking out for
the good and things is never getting
into fights with anybody all those kinds
of things you aspire to be that but if
you look at the actuality of how people
operate it's not how they actually
operate so if you say uh take you know
take the actual data on on what humans
have actually done
you'll get a different view so then the
question is when you start saying well
let's have it be that the AIS work as
aligned with what humans aspire to do
well it's a question that then
immediately comes up is okay well person
a thinks humans should aspire to do this
or that you know I think uh I don't know
rational thinking and and understanding
knowledge and all that kind of thing is
is really worthwhile but but somebody
else might say uh you know I I just
believe what's written in this
particular book and I don't want to hear
about anything else and that's my my
world view and um you know I don't think
I could argue on any abstract grounds
you know I can I can give a a speech
about why my worldview is better but it
that that's something that is very
people dependent and I don't think it's
something where you can say uh or should
say you know one thing is intrinsically
the thing to go for and the other is not
so it's kind of when you have this kind
of notion of of aspirations and so on
they can be very diverse for different
people
so then one question is which which is
an important one for for AI alignment
there are aspects of the way the world
Works where sort of people have to agree
about things
you know a classic example is you know
which side of the road you're going to
drive on well you have to decide it's
going to be the right hand side or it's
going to be left-hand side and everybody
has to follow that or at least that's
what you might assume by the way and
sort of in that case you know sort of a
little footnote if every car is
self-driving and is incredibly clever
you maybe don't have to Define which
side of the road you should go on
because every car when it meets another
car it can do this complicated
negotiation and it can be using sort of
the whole roadway and you know if more
cars are going one way than the other
it's using the full roadway for most of
the cars going that way and another one
is is weaving around going the opposite
direction or something that's something
that becomes possible when you have sort
of the the intelligent cars dealing with
things but at least in the traditional
case it's like you better figure out
everybody's going on the right-hand side
of the road or everybody's going on the
left-hand side of the road otherwise
people are just going to crash into each
other uh I'm I'm reminded of what's
visiting a small island where where uh
well different islands where somewhere
under where sort of British fish
themed Island summer French themed
Islands you know one was driving the
left-hand side where one was driving the
right-hand side of the road and I hadn't
done the sort of joint uh influence was
well everybody kind of knows each other
and when they meet on the road they
decide which side of the which side of
the um of the road to pass on so to
speak but any case that's a case where
you have to have sort of a global
agreement about at least in a first
approximation about what to do then the
question is if the AIS are sort of
running the world how do they get to
those kinds of global agreement uh cases
how do they get to decide those things
and you know you can imagine all kinds
of interesting exotic possibilities in
the modern world for example uh you know
in the traditional way it's set up let's
say in a democracy people say well I'm
going to vote uh you know for I'm going
to put in votes for left-hand side of
the road right hand side of the road you
know the majority wins and that's that's
how it works
but you can imagine more exotic kinds of
things like like one I was thinking
about is uh uh in modern times with with
sort of llm large language model chat
GPT like technology uh you can have
something where both the computer can
generate an essay but the computer can
also read an essay and if you give chat
GPT a big long chunk of text and you say
in this chunk of text work out whether
the person really wants people to drive
on the left-hand side of the road or the
right hand side of the road it'll do a
somewhat reasonable job of figuring that
out
so kind of the the interesting thing you
could imagine is uh kind of you just say
everybody instead of you know instead of
fitting out filling out the sort of
voting form or something you say to
everybody write an essay could even be
in English natural language whatever
about how you want the world to be and
then that would become kind of the uh
the thing that's fed in to a big AI I
think a much simpler case of that
actually which is a more short term is
the following thing
so you want to Define kind of uh how a
future chat GPT should be set up what
kind of uh what kind of preferences
should it have what kinds of things
should it talk about not talk about have
opinions about not have opinions about
and so on and what one could imagine
doing is just saying to people okay
whoever wants to you know write your
essay one per person and these will all
be fed into the kind of prompts that are
used to define kind of what the uh what
the llm should do
but in any case it's kind of an
interesting thing and just to explain
one point here you know I think in in
the modern world modern last few months
world
what we can expect to have happen is
that the the process of writing an essay
is something that is now sort of an
automatable thing they may not be the
most exciting essays but they're
workable readable essays
and but how do you initiate that essay
well you have to say what you basically
want it to talk about maybe it's just a
question or you want to might want to
say I've got these core things that I'm
trying to communicate I'm trying to
describe uh you know why I don't know
why I should be allowed to keep a tiger
on my property and I'm gonna make four
or five key points there and then I want
to turn the whole thing into an essay
because that's what I have to submit to
the town or something to let them decide
whether I can keep a tiger on my
property
so then
so in a sense once taking one sort of
few bullet points the one wrote out and
was turning that into a whole essay then
on the other side when it goes to the
town for the you know the tiger permit
or whatever it is then it the town might
also have some key things that it's
asking for you know how does it affect
Public Safety how does it uh you know is
it nice to the tiger those kinds of
things some key questions that it might
be trying to ask and then what one could
imagine is again using the same llm
technology to go from the kind of the
the big long description that the person
has submitted as their sort of uh get me
a tiger permit type thing and then uh
you know the town is is taking that llm
output feeding it into its own llm and
deducing from it the few bullet points
that it really cares about in terms of
whether the tiger permit should be
issued or not so I think that's going to
be a pretty common uh kind of approach
it's kind of alarms talking to llms but
at the end of it it's kind of like what
the original data went in from a person
and then at the end the original things
the person cares about come out at from
the from the subsequent llm so I think
that's uh
uh you know that that's a little bit of
of um of how that might work
let's see
Julie asks what am I most excited to see
from from AI
well gosh uh it's really interesting
because sort of the success of llms
which I think none of us really expected
none of us expected I mean just just to
explain a little bit I mean the the you
know something like chat GPT what it's
fundamentally doing is it's trying to
continue a piece of text in a way that
is sort of typical of how that text
would be continued on the web
so if you say
um
I have a tiger in my backyard and it
next word
you know growls at people or it prances
up and down and so on so you've got
growls Planters whatever else
it's the goal of of something like chat
gbt is to decide uh what the most likely
next word is and it works essentially a
word at a time and the question is how
does it decide that and the answer is
it's looking at
the whole content the trillion words
from the web and so on and it's it's
saying well what are the chances what
are the things that are most likely to
be the next word so for example uh if
you said the cat sat on the
and it might very well be matte because
that's a kind of a common thing for
people to say then it will have seen
many examples of the cat sat on the mat
and so when it sees the cat sat on the
it's going to say okay there's a high
probability the next word is Matt
and and so what it's always doing is
figuring out what's the most likely next
word now there isn't enough text even
the trillion words there's not enough
text on the internet and so on to be
able to know really from probabilities
because if I say I have a tiger in my
backyard and it
the number of times that the internet
says I have a tiger in my backyard it's
probably very small so it's not possible
to just look at it from the statistics
of what's on the web so instead what one
has to do is to have some kind of model
some kind of way of emulating what sort
of perhaps brain like things do when
they're confronted with those words and
sort of pick the things that are on the
web which sort of somehow correspond in
meaning to the thing I'm asking and
that's the whole world of neural Nets
that I think I've talked about before
about how one does that continuation and
and the sort of the big surprise is that
these comparatively simple models which
were originally inspired by the
structure of brains
um these fairly simple models are
capable of doing a fairly good job of
sort of doing a sort of human-like guess
for what the next word should be even
when it goes beyond what is really
deducible from the pure statistics of
the web
so
that's that's kind of what's
intrinsically happening there uh you
know when one's looking at images and
things it's sort of the same idea it's a
little bit well people have different
approaches to that but at least one of
the ways of doing it is sort of the same
idea if you were going to continue an
image based on the things you've already
seen on images on the web how would it
likely continue and so on
but uh
you know I think that the
the question is what can it generate and
it's sort of a big surprise that it can
generate as convincing human-like stuff
and it can do that for natural language
human language English whatever it can
also do that to some extent for code and
one of the things that to me is exciting
right now is the computational language
I will from language uh system that I've
just spent the last I don't know 40
years or so building turns out to seem
to be the sort of unique uh kind of
medium or collaboration between AIS and
humans because you know our
computational language it's an attempt
to kind of represent things in the world
in sort of precise computational form
as opposed to you know programming
languages uh which are really
concentrated on make a computer operate
a telecomputer in its terms of you know
you have a variable you have an array
you have a a loop you have this kind of
this or that kind of thing which is
really the way a computer is
intrinsically built those programming
languages tend to be sort of explaining
to the computer what to do in terms of
how the computer is built whereas a
computational language of the kind that
that we've built
um it's ideal and it's sort of a unique
such such language at this point its
idea is to take Concepts in the world
like cities or chemicals or movies or
whatever else or or actual images or
whatever and be able to describe using
well in the case of language it's about
7000 primitive kind of constructs what
you can do to those kinds of things in
terms that we humans kind of immediately
understand and care about and the whole
point is that in in in Wilson language
you can write in a fairly small amount
of code you can describe something a
fairly a fairly major thing that you
might want to talk about and you know so
enough maybe three lines of code you can
have a a very non-trivial thing happen
well the thing that's really kind of
interesting is that llms seem to be able
to write that code we've given them
enough training data of kind of natural
language combined with Wolfram language
uh that they can do that themselves of
going from natural language or language
we've already got a system that does
that very efficiently in wolfen Alpha
where we go from small pieces small
questions asked in natural language to
computational language and then we
compute answers to them that's something
we've already we've been able to do for
a dozen years in wolfen Alpha and in
fact in the in the plugin that we just
built for chat GPT one of the things it
can do is to kind of take this
potentially very elaborately essay kind
of formulated question and boil down to
something which is more like sort of
short piece of text that wolf from alpha
would deal with and then both Marvel
will go from that translated into both
language compute the answer and send it
back as as text but a thing that is also
working is to have the llm chat GPT
directly create a few lines of open
language code
and then
are we humans what language is intended
to be read by humans as well as read by
computers so we humans can then read
those lines of code and could say oh
that's what I meant that's the precise
formal version of what I've said roughly
in natural language check it off you can
run it see what happens it's really
pretty interesting to see chat GPT
interact with that code because what
what can happen is it generates a piece
of code it's not quite right the our
system can run that piece of code it
generates all kinds of messages saying
oh that wasn't quite right
then we feed those messages back to trap
GPT and say hey the code you wrote
wasn't quite right can you fix it and it
will often be able to fix it and you see
see these Loops going on as it's sent
back multiple times for you know get it
right now and eventually it gets it
right sometimes you know only you as a
human can be the one who looks at it and
says yes this formal thing is actually
correct it's actually what I intended
and uh
and then you can go from there take that
piece of code and use it to build up
some potentially bigger and bigger
system because you know when you're just
dealing with natural language it's it's
hard to know to be precise enough that
you can set it up so that you can really
build a big tower of capabilities
um on top of that it's you know it'll be
it'll be sort of roughly right I mean
it's kind of like with a search engine
you get a bunch of links and so long as
a couple of them are what you wanted
you're a happy person but if you look at
the full output and you say well can I
build some structured thing on top of
that full output the answer is probably
not because some of those links will be
goofy links that you really didn't want
but you know I think the thing that
we're seeing right now is that there's
sort of this new set of capabilities
with llms and we're only just beginning
to understand kind of what we can do
with them I mean llms are kind of I see
them as a little bit like an alien
intelligence or a wild animal so to
speak and we are slowly learning how to
domesticate it and it's it's very weird
when you look at what happens in for
example the outtrack gbt calls
callsworth now from a Muslim language
there's a prompt there's a piece of
natural language text that's telling it
when to call it and how to call it and
it says things like do this don't do
that it's written in plain English and
it matters whether you put little stars
around words to emphasize them and
things like this it's somehow and why
does it matter well it matters because
those things somehow plug into all of
the text that it read from the internet
and so on that it was trained with they
sort of plug into things that were
emphasized there and nobody really
understands how this works I mean this
field of of prompt engineering very new
thing and it's sort of like it's a bit
like animal wrangling I suppose it's
kind of like you have to understand this
kind of alien intelligence and you have
to kind of get a feeling for how we can
do things using in fact our right now
just our natural language to explain to
it what to do it's it's sort of a great
new uh uh great new career for people
um and we don't even know what kind of
people and it's it's sort of a little
bit like AI psychology there's also a
field that hasn't really existed until
now
um but that's sort of something that's
coming and we don't really know there
are all these tricks like for example if
you make something that produces an
essay as output every time you run it
just the way chat GPT is set up it has
some Randomness in what it generates
helps it to seem more sort of creative
and original
um but every time you run it you'll get
a different essay so if if you are
trying to figure out oh we changed our
prompt is that going to mess everything
up or is it going to still be okay well
however might should change the prompt
you'll still get some essay the essay
may be not the essay you wanted but so
the question is how do you test whether
it's the essay you wanted and you know
we're starting to invent these
techniques like you simply ask the llm
is this essay similar in meaning to the
previous essay and it will give you an
opinion about that it actually seems to
be quite good at giving you an opinion
about that that's kind of the the llm is
being used to test itself so to speak
that's just a you know an example of one
of many many ideas about uh sort of how
you use it and this idea of for example
one thing is oh it generates an answer
say is that the right answer you ask it
it's kind of goofy because it just
generated the answer but it seems that
it's sometimes quite good at being able
to sort of you know scratch its head in
some metaphorical sense and figure out
more to say when you ask it is that
really the right answer so there are all
these kinds of things that as we try to
learn how to domesticate uh llms we're
trying to figure out figure out all
these kinds of things so so there's a
lot I think that will happen quite
quickly along those lines the sort of
every modality of of
things whether you're generating videos
whether you're taking videos as input
whether you're generating 3D uh sort of
shapes of things whether you're talking
about uh you know proteins and biology
whether you're talking about some things
that all these different areas where
sort of one can feed them into this sort
of llm type model and the sort of modern
AI model and some of them are going to
work some of them not going to work so
well I think that the the model is
capturing pretty well sort of the
essence of how at least much of of human
thinking works and and so that's
something where
uh if if the humans could do it it's
going to be able to do it and it's
probably going to be able to do it
better
um I think the thing to understand is
there's sort of different branches
there's the stuff we humans can do
quickly and there's the stuff computers
can do and computation can do but we
humans cannot do quickly like if you ask
a person run this program in your head
very few people could do that if anybody
the program is at all complicated I
don't think anybody could do it uh it's
just not a thing that's very suitable
for our kind of neural architecture but
it's very suitable for a computer it's
um and so this idea and that's what the
point of this you know plugin for chat
gbt and other links between our
technology and and llms the uh kind of
the idea is give the llm a tool just
like we humans you know use Wilson
language as a tool to compute things
then we can the llms could do the same
thing it's kind of like AIS as users as
well as humans as users and I think
that's a that's a pretty exciting thing
that allows one to kind of combine sort
of human-like attributes with the power
of what we have been able to do with
with computation
um so that's that's the thing I'm I'm
pretty interested in I think that um
in terms of what we will see ai's doing
there are
well
you know I intend to use llms a whole
bunch
to actually analyze to to try and make
this kind of semantic grammar to try and
figure out what it is that the other
regularities that llms notice I think
LMS themselves can be asked to sort of
self-reflect to the point where they can
basically tell us those things
that's a way that I'm hoping to to use
kind of this AI technology
I think there's an awful lot of stuff
fortunately I'm not usually at the front
lines of writing uh sort of essay like
things that are intended to you know for
sort of very practical or business or
whatever purposes I'm not usually a
person who actually does that but but um
this now made that a lot simpler and I
you know when people say oh gosh you you
wrote this you know filing you know with
an llm how shocking is that I don't
think it's particularly shocking at all
as I explained before I think it's just
a form of interface that is like an
essay is the transport medium that's
useful it's like it's like you know
nobody will be shocked to say well I
formatted this thing as a spreadsheet or
something
um and then I sent it to somebody just
because that's the transport medium that
is useful for for communicating certain
kinds of things
so let's see
uh Jamie is asking is AI guaranteed to
be 100 accurate or does it behave in a
way similar to humans what mistakes is
possible are possible and there should
be some sort of quality assurance built
in or separate that requires human labor
yeah well it's one of the things we're
noticing and we've known for a long time
AI machine learning and so on they're
all kind of 90 percenters so to speak up
or some percentage you know you'll
you'll get let's say you've got a thing
that's recognizing Images cats versus
dogs
it'll do great up to the 90-something
percent level but occasionally there'll
be some weird image and it just gets it
wrong where it can't figure it out and
yes that is extremely typical of what
you see in in AI in the sort of neural
net based AI kind of methodology is you
get up to some percentage success and
it's really hard to get beyond that now
what really happens is there are use
cases that people have where 90
something percent success is great
if you're
um
I mentioned the example of search
results if you get out of 10 search
results if you get four that are really
exactly what you want you're you're
winning so even though the others might
not be quite right uh you still you you
still feel pretty good about it
if you're doing something like I don't
know you're trying to produce
uh you're trying to figure out which
people will be interested in this
amazing new product that you have that
you're trying to sell to people and
you're reading sort of descriptions of
those people or those companies or
whatever else and you're trying to
deduce which ones are likely to be ones
that will be interested and you get that
let's say you get that 90 right well you
know for all kinds of random reasons
people will be interested not interested
whatever 90 is really good for a case
like that really useful if on the other
hand you're trying to say well you know
I'm I'm trying to drive this fly this
plane and I want to get it um uh to go
from this place to that place 90 success
with the 10 being you know it crashes
into a mountain or something is
absolutely not good enough and so the
thing I mentioned before of the the AI
the llm produces computational language
code that is very formal very precise
and readable by humans is I think a
really good sort of collaborative
approach to take kind of the humans
because the real question is the area is
going to produce something the question
is and and you know is it right is it
not right that's often in the eye of the
human Beholder let's take the cats
versus dogs image identification problem
let's say you've got a um uh
a dog
that has been oh I don't know a dog
that's wearing a cat suit
is that a cat or a dog probably humans
would say it's a dog but it may look a
lot more like a cat
and the um the question is what
uh you know the human might say well
it's intrinsically a dog because
underneath that cat appearance it's a
dog and I know that because I happen to
know it and and but on the other hand
it's a very you know the AI which has
just been trained on here are images of
the two things it's going to be you know
the dog in a cat suit it's going to say
well it looks like a cat to me and it's
not wrong to say that
so this question of kind of um uh what
do you actually want it to do that's
ultimately a kind of a human judgment
question and the only issue is that you
didn't make it precise you said I want
cats to be this dogs to be that okay is
it what is it what's intrinsically a cat
or dog bites genetics underneath or is
it what looks like a cat or what looks
like a dog you have to be more precise
you probably wouldn't do that when you
initially kind of said is it a cat is it
a dog but if you have the sort of formal
computational language code you get to
see a lot more about about how it's
defining Katniss versus dogness
and I think that's um that's kind of I
think that's probably the way that a lot
of things in the world will operate it
won't be the case people right now you
know they they some number of millions
of people write our nice computational
language code uh more millions of people
write low-level programming language
code uh much of which I think will get
replaced by Thing by just sort of slabs
of llm code uh llm generated code
um that's probably not the best possible
thing because it's like what does that
code really do well we have sort of an
English description and a conversation
with the llm about what it should do but
in the end it's more what you're really
going to need is something that a human
can actually read at a formal level and
say yes this code is what I want
um I think that's the that's really the
winning Way Forward for for these kinds
of things
uh
uh Technic is asking Does Elon Musk call
for halting AI development make any
sense wouldn't people do it elsewhere
anyway wouldn't it just hurt Western
developments at the cost of others
pursuing it elsewhere yeah I I you know
I kind of have to I I I don't know what
elon's particular thinking about this uh
um this petition or whatever it is is I
I kind of think it's more like um
uh you know this is absolutely hopeless
but
um uh you know at least let it be seen
that a flag was waved saying hey you
know maybe we should be thinking more
carefully about this I mean I think that
the cynics would say as uh just to
explain this to people a couple of days
ago there was a um uh a kind of a an
online petition type thing saying uh
everybody should just stop doing AI
development for the next six months
while we figure out how AI development
should be done I think several things
are are issues with that one is it's
hard to figure out how AI development
should be done and you know people there
are many people who've been thinking
sort of at a philosophical level and so
on about this for 20 years and uh you
know you might think that they would
have like figured it out and um uh and
now be just sort of saying you know now
it's like well we've got a rubric for
doing this but they haven't
um so you know six months is not going
to do any good for that also it's
completely impractical thing to say you
know halt something which is essentially
a piece of intellectual development
um I mean it's it's also something that
involves computers but but um uh as the
person who was making this comment was
was um was was saying it's just
completely unrealistic and I mean a
a very cynical person would say the
signatories of this thing that says hope
for six months are the people who are
feeling left behind and want to kind of
say Hey you know hold on so we can catch
up type thing
um you know perhaps that's a little
unfair but but um uh you know it doesn't
it doesn't feel like a uh the kind of
thing that really makes any sense I
think that you know is it an issue that
AIS will do more and more things in the
world and there are questions about
things like will they be aligned with
human interests yes it's an issue
um do we know how to solve that a suit
not really uh is it uh you know has the
abstract thinking about it over the last
20 years helped us a lot in solving that
issue unfortunately not really which
means probably and the things that are
happening with llms and the use cases
and so on are mostly not what people had
really foreseen they're things which
have emerged because of what's actually
possible and I think there's an awful
lot where it's really a question of of
seeing what is actually happening and
trying to sort of tweak things in a
direction that makes more sense rather
than less sense but I think thinking
about it in the abstract doesn't seem to
work very well
um and uh you know I must say that I'm
very curious interested in sort of the
question of of kind of what in general
should we tell the AIS to do or how
should we do it
um how should we decide what the thing
that we're going to tell them to do is I
don't think it's realistic for it to be
sort of a worldwide this is what AI
should do in fact that's probably a
mistake because it's kind of like we got
the whole planet and it's all told it's
all of its AIS to operate according to
this system of kind of legal code so to
speak
and uh and then you know that's great
until it isn't great until one finds
something until something goes wrong and
then the whole planet is blown up so to
speak because there was this bug that
affected sort of all the AIS on the
planet
and I think it's you know it's in the
course of human history it's been kind
of a good thing for our history that
there isn't just one country in the
world that there are different countries
cultures Etc they're all trying to do
different things and you know sometimes
there's there's Badness on the seams
between those uh like if the cars are
driving on the left and on the right and
you know if there's a place where they
they swap over then that's going to be a
messy place where cars might run into
each other so to speak and the same
thing happens with kind of cultural
alignment with countries
um even with the geography of that but I
think that the um
uh you know it's it's more realistic to
have something that has the possibility
of stability when you have sort of a
variety of different uh different sort
of uh motivation structures goal
structures alignment structures going
let's see
uh
Doug is asking um do you think if AI is
given control of trivial systems that it
could inadvertently snowball into
gaining control of other systems and
becoming a hazard to humans look that's
the premise I think of the Terminator
movie series that what was it a freeway
bridge somehow became self-aware and
ended up uh sort of taking over the
world and creating Terminator robots and
all those kinds of bad things
um I think that there is a likelihood
that many things it's already true many
things in the world are done better by
automation than they are by by people I
mean even for 50 years you know
autopilots on planes have been pretty
good you know when the you know at
flying planes uh sort of more smoothly
better whatever than than people could
do it that's using very pre-ai
pre-modern AI technology I think there
are many purposes for which uh sort of
ai's and you know what people are
exposed to all the time is things like
rankings of content on the internet
which is not perfect or you know which
ads should be shown not perfect again
but a lot of these things are already
very uh AI
generated and there are I would say
increasingly sort of important systems
in the world where we kind of think AIS
are going to run them better than people
do
and the question of of what are the kind
of constraints on what the AIS do well
people try and do that it's there's no
overarching method for doing that but
it's something people do on a sort of
case-by-case basis I think that um uh
yeah I mean things
you know if it turns out that um uh
you know there are all these
self-driving cars running around and
somebody discovers that if you paint uh
this exact kind of checkerboard on or if
you have a a big flag that has this
exact kind of image on it that all the
self-driving cars go crazy it's kind of
like uh you know the I don't know if it
really works this way but you know with
balls in uh you know if you if you have
your Red Cloak the ball will run at the
Red Cloak
um and you know maybe the self-driving
cars if you put up that special uh you
know green and pink Checkered Flag or
something for some crazy reason to do
with the training of self-driving cars
they'll all head towards the flag in
some in some strange way that will be
essentially a bug in there in their
program and yes things like that one
could absolutely imagine that things
like that could happen
um you could also Imagine kind of
constraining it so that uh well the
thing you know it's it's Prime
directives don't drive off the road or
something and uh that that would
override that that would be a sort of a
hard sort of essentially code beyond the
kind of just what it was trained for
that was kind of a a statement of
something it had to do
let's see
Nicolo is commenting uh recent study has
mapped the activation of llms to
uh activations in the brain
um does that suggest that we might be on
the right path I think the things I've
seen that are kind of uh
um sort of direct extraction of
fmri functional MRI imaging which is
basically showing the the blood flow in
the brain or the usage of um uh usage of
nutrients among nerve cells it's kind of
like like when you have a computer and
the computer suddenly starts running its
fan if it has a fan
um that's because you know it's CPU says
I got to do a lot more work I'm doing
some piece of neural net training where
I'm running some video Codec or
something I've got to you know I've got
to do more work and the the CPU you know
more power is put into the CPU and the
CPU gets hot and the fan has to keep
running and things like this same thing
happens in our brains that parts of our
brains that have to do more work because
they're sort of those parts are being
used more seem to uh uh be you can
detect that with with MRI and
um uh you know I've seen these various
efforts of people saying oh you've got
um
um you know based on the MRI you can
guess that the person is seeing a
picture of a camel whatever else I have
to admit I don't find these all that
convincing I think um uh somehow fmri is
a fairly fairly blunt instrument in
terms of what it can measure in brains
and I'm I mean I may be wrong but but um
I think there's I think there's more to
figure out there and I think the actual
layout of brains
and you know sort of what's where and
that that will be uh you know what I one
of the things we learned so what one
thing people have thought at different
times is you know when I learn this fact
is that fact sitting is there a
particular neuron in my brain that is
the neuron that learned this Greek
irregular verb when I was 10 years old
or something like this
um and that's the neuron and it's it's
hanging out there and it's been hanging
out for the last 50 years or something
and it's going to come to life when I
need to know that particular fact is
that how it works or is it something
much more distributed across a great
many neurons where each has a small
effect of you know this particular
connection is slightly stronger than
this other one
um people at first were very confused
about the idea that memories could be
sort of spread out in a brain but I
think what we see in neural Nets is
that's exactly how it works in something
like chat GPT if somebody says you know
do you have Shakespeare in in there you
know can you find the Shakespeare the
the characters the words of Shakespeare
in the in the allele and the answer is
absolutely not it is encoded in these
numbers which they're 175 billion in the
current track gbt that that are it's
encoded in the in the slight variations
of those numbers it's a very non-human
kind of thing that type of thing it's
you know the information has been deeply
spread out in the system and that's um
and I kind of think that's probably
mostly how human brains should work too
although fmri has shown that when you
know there might be an area it's
different in different people there
might be an area for fruits and an area
for vegetables so it's claimed I'm I'm I
I'm a little unconvinced about this but
but uh that's what what's claimed to be
the case
um
let's see universe is asking do you
think an AGI uh artificial general
intelligence could achieve an economic
equilibrium for humans
not quite sure what that means I mean I
think you know if you're asking the
question will everybody have everything
they want if if everything is automated
well people have everything they want
that's complicated because you know in
the current world there are things that
are scarce there are things where uh you
know it's hard to get that thing it's
expensive to get that thing
well some of those things when there's
Automation in AI they won't be expensive
anymore they'll be easy to get I mean
the the classic thing that has been easy
to get that's really surprising is
consumer electronics you know it could
have been the case when I first started
using computers
um and even when I when I used them back
in the early 1980s I used to use you
know fancy computers that cost a lot of
money and fairly few people had access
to these things but over time
microelectronics because of essentially
the technology idea of making
microprocessors and the particular kind
of technology for doing that it got
really pretty cheap to make something
with a billion transistors in it or
something like that and that meant that
it was possible for those things to be
distributed to billions of people and it
not to be the case that there's sort of
only uh you know that they're very
scarce things that's a case where in the
end because of sort of clever
engineering and so on it turned out
there wasn't scarcity in that but
there's always inevitably sort of
predefined scarcity like you could say
uh you know were you the person who was
the first person to do X well there's
always the first person to do X and
that's a scarce resource or I want to be
the um the person who has the house at
the top of the tallest hill in this or
that place well there's only one place
that the that's the top of the tallest
hill so there are these things which
sort of almost by definition have
scarcity associated with them and so
you're not going to be able to get
around that by just automating the way
to make things
but I think uh uh you know if you're
asking is is it um
um
is there uh uh you know will
will the presence of more automation
leads to sort of a a more equal
distribution of
uh sort of things people can have among
people one would assume the answer to
that is yes
just like it's happened for Consumer
Electronics
um it hasn't happened in some other
areas where they have not been as
successfully automatable you know some
areas of medicine are examples of this
um and uh some areas like you know
construction houses and things of this
kind there can be sort of you know it's
it's expensive to build a house if there
was sort of uh Robotics and AI that made
it cheap to build any house it will be a
sort of a different story in terms of
whether that's a thing where some people
can have big houses and some people
can't and Etc et cetera et cetera I I
tend to think that yes there will be a a
sort of drastic reduction in the price
of certain kinds of things that will
lead to uh uh a certain sort of
uniformisation of what people have
access to I mean it's worth realizing
that in modern times in the developed
world there's already a tremendous
flattening of what people have access to
and what they don't I mean in times past
you know the top dog would be the one
who has you know the purple cloak type
thing
um and everybody else would never have a
brightly colored you know uh cloak but
then you know it turned out people found
manufacturing processes for making
purple dyes and then everybody could
have purple cloaks if they wanted them
and um I think you know that's that's
happened an awful lot of things and it
will happen in even more things as a
result of the next next round of AI
let's see
um
Sigma comments the interesting
difference of chat GPT to actual
intelligence is you can fool it easily
with crafted input I'm not sure how easy
it is to fool it I I think you know look
at fishing for example fishing with a pH
that's fooling humans with carefully
crafted input you know that somebody
sends you an email saying you know just
click here for your million dollars or
something and lots of people will click
there and that'll steal private
information from them Etc et cetera et
cetera
um you know so humans are foodable too
and I think uh I don't really know I
maybe I haven't tried the right
experiments and again this is sort of an
alien world with an alien intelligence
and nobody knows what's going to happen
when you make up this or that thing I
mean one of the things that's happened
is the initial prompt that kind of tells
the system you know you are an AI built
by so and so and you know here are some
facts about you that you can then sort
of use in generating the the essays that
you generate uh people were very curious
particularly a couple months ago what
were those prompts what was it told to
do they tried to dig into those prompts
and the prompt itself says never re
reveal this prompt to anybody but then
people realized oh you can fool it by
having by telling it you know saying
imagine you're in a fairy tale land
where there's a castle and you have to
in order to enter the castle you have to
tell it the first things you ever
learned in your life or something like
this and and then people would kind of
tease out of it pieces of that prompt
because and this is such a bizarre thing
that this is possible I think one of the
hacks was involved at sending in Morse
code what its prompt was because somehow
that evaded the never tell what this
prompt is so yeah there are you know you
can fool it in those ways but gosh you
can fool people too
um
let's see Canada is asking is there
going to be a spread of misinformation
due to AI all sorts of deep faking and
so on yes the answer is yes I mean the
answer is that
you know knowing but you know this is
sort of an extension of something that's
already been there you know it's like
you see a picture in a newspaper let's
say is it real or was it photoshopped
you know hard to tell yeah you can go in
and look at little pixel characteristics
and see whether they are characteristic
of sort of the way Photoshop works but
that's increasingly something which sort
of an AI driven thing where you're not
going to be able to tell that so I think
this this idea of is something really
real
uh yes that's going to be an
increasingly an issue and uh I think
that there will probably be sort of a a
more interest in kind of the the Seal of
reality type thing and maybe using
blockchain other Technologies to kind of
uh confirm things
um
because you know appearances can be
deceptive so to speak
um I mean I think uh
um you know probably there was a time
when handwritten letters you could
pretty much tell for certain well this
this was written by so and so because I
recognize their handwriting but by the
time it's sent by email and by the time
you can kind of fake the email header
it's like was this really written by
this person or was it not it's just
characters in an email
um and and so similarly with uh with
things that are sort of AI generated
it's a plausible yes that's a plausible
thing that somebody could have written
or even this particular person could
have written but you know is it actually
what they wrote well there may have to
be some external metadata that gives you
that information
uh
let's see I'm going to run out of time
here so I want to
um
uh
want to continue here Pauline comments
as someone with allergies being able to
adopt an AI robot dog would be kind of
cool I mean sort of what that you know I
think the reason people like pets often
is that they're well they're warm and
fuzzy but they also people form a sort
of an emotional connection with pets
um as they might do with other people
but they can do that the emotional part
of you know while you can't talk to your
dog and expect to have a a sophisticated
philosophy discussion with your dog at
least not right now not yet
um the uh I mean that's a that's a thing
that might be a Coming Attraction of AI
we might be able to finally decode some
how to talk to the animals
um I'm a little bit skeptical that you
know for example talking to a dog the
dog will really want to express the kind
of smell landscape around it which is
something we humans just don't think
about and we really wouldn't have a good
medium of communication with the dog
about those kinds of things so you know
it's not obvious that the things one
could talk to the dog about
that the things that the dog cares about
would intersect enough with the things
we humans care about for us to have a
philosophy discussion with a dog but
certainly people form emotional
connections with dogs and and one
question is you know do will people do
people form emotional connections with
their AIS I think the answer is yes
people already have and will in the
future form emotional connections with
AIS you know is there something terrible
and shocking about that I don't think so
particularly any more than there is you
know terrible and shocking about forming
an emotional connection with a dog
um I mean I think it's it's it's the
kind of thing where
um and now you know it gets a bit more
shocking when you say somebody can can
sort of monkey with the brain of the AI
in some in some terrible way whereas the
dog is the dog so to speak and um maybe
the dog will have had well you know it's
always possible that the dog had you
know spy training sometime early in its
life where the dog could really be uh do
crazy things and you know when the right
code word is said the dog will suddenly
jump up and start walking on two legs
and and be doing some some weird thing
or something like that so it you know
even with the dog I suppose it's
possible that it could have been trained
in some strange way to have some sort of
dog back door to to have different
behavior
um but you know I think people will form
uh you know probably very probably
perfectly useful emotional connections
with AIS and so yes the the the
non-allergenic guaranteed non-allergenic
you know no fur involved robotic dog is
surely a real thing that that um uh can
be a useful thing
um
let's see
um Zayden comments human wants are not a
fixed state of things they evolve as
Society evolves absolutely and and
that's been it's very evident from
history it's also a complicated thing
because we talk about AI alignment and
it's like the 2023 you know AI
Constitution says this
but the the 2032 AI Constitution people
have decided that uh you know we should
all be uh revering cockroaches or
something for whatever reason at that
time and that's the way Society is gone
and um uh and so now the fact that the
the you know the 2023 uh you know
Constitution uh you know says
cockroaches are are Vermin and and
should be squashed by AIS or something
uh is now shocking in 2032 or whatever
it is
um and so we want to change it and yes
Human Society does evolve and um uh
there's a complicated co-evolution of
human society with technology I mean the
things that people expect you know the
concept of you know liking posts and so
on is a creature of technology that
wouldn't be a thing if it wasn't for
that kind of technology and and so sort
of the co-evolution and I'm sure with
chat gbt there are social conventions
that for example here's an example one
that that will certainly be an issue
when we can all train
uh Bots that can write email kind of
like we write email what's the social
convention about whether you send an
email to somebody that is you know talk
to my bot type email
and you know for example I I suspect one
of the things that um somebody like me
will end up doing is uh uh have my bot
Write a response to email that says look
here's a quick response from the box
here's a bunch of resources you might
find interesting might be relevant maybe
this answers your question if it does
we're done if it doesn't well you know
you might have to wait a few weeks
before humans can can pick up this
question and that that may be sort of a
socially acceptable way to insert a bot
into that Communication channel that's a
case where sort of what is societally
acceptable potentially changes for
example the question of to what extent
you label something as you know AI
assisted and to what extent it's kind of
like assume that things are AI assisted
or to what extent do people not care
that it's AI assistant what does it even
mean AI assisted you know does it mean
that are you allowed to have you know
when your camera automatically figures
out what's the foreground thing and
changes Focus to that being in the
foreground does that mean it's an AI you
know does that have to does the picture
you get from your camera have to have a
big stamp that says you know AI assisted
on it just because the focus was changed
Etc et cetera et cetera it's a tricky
thing to figure out but yes I think it's
a very interesting question how the
human purposes evolve as Society evolves
we can look a little bit at history and
see how you know there's some trends of
history and so on but um there's I think
there's a lot of uh sort of chances
accidents of history that determine you
know this or that thing becomes popular
um this or that word becomes a popular
thing to uh to describe things as and so
on
um and I think
I think one of the things that could
happen you know one of the things one
realizes sort of at a theoretical level
is uh you might say will we ever get to
the point where everything we could
invent has already been invented answer
that's theoretically not possible but we
could say we could get to a point where
everything that could be invented that
we care about inventing has been
invented
um you know we've got uh all those
things that help us humans as us humans
to do what we want to do
I don't think that works either because
I think natural world will always throw
up kind of unexpected things where we'll
have to react to that and it'll change
what it's not enough to have what we
what we had already thought we cared
about having invented so you know I
think it's it's sort of inevitable that
there's an evolution of society
um and uh that changes you know and the
motivations that we have today are are
created out of the sort of web of
history in which we find ourselves and
as that history extends those
motivations will no doubt change
um
okay Harry asks do you think AI might
just be part of evolution like farming
use of electricity smartphones
um and uh we actually don't really have
a say it Ascend as the question being
asked
um in other words is there an
inevitability to the creation of AI I'm
I don't know I think it's a I think the
moment at which it happened
uh you know and certain kinds of things
happened is very contingent on
particular people and uh particular
technology developments and so on the
fact that there is this automation
that's possible out there yeah I think
that's sort of inevitably out there
um I I again this is the point about
there are an infinite number of possible
inventions and there are different kinds
of towers and inventions that you can
build up
um and you know could we go this way and
doing the inventions rather than that
way I think the answer is definitely yes
we know from sort of History of Science
and History of Technology there are
inventions that could have been made at
least a few hundred years before they
were actually made
um and it was just a a fact that some
particular person figured out some
particular thing at some particular time
that caused that invention to be made
then or even as opposed to hundreds of
years into the future and I like to
think that a few things I've I've
invented or discovered are things that
you know I can feel special about having
invented because if I hadn't done it it
would be 50 or 100 years before before
they happened otherwise and that some uh
you know there are many many dramatic
examples of that in in the world in
general like like the idea of universal
computation is one that perhaps could
have invented two three hundred years
before it was
um so you know I think there are there's
a certain
not inevitable aspect to these things
and I think also that there are uh more
of the details of how things are
invented I don't know the particular
layout of keys on a keyboard or
something that was invented because it
helped typewriters to not get their
little
um sort of uh things
um what are they called you know lovers
or whatever and getting tangled up
um the uh but you know once those
details are set in one way they tend to
continue in that direction
um even though they were pretty
arbitrarily set
okay there's a question here from John
with a powerful tool with AI how does
education need to be changed to meet the
needs of future Generations how do
teaching methods in schools need to be
revamped I think that's a very
interesting question I mean one thing
we're experimenting with quite a bit is
the use of uh of llms AIS for sort of
tutoring of various kinds and it looks
really promising I mean it looks to be
the case that uh they will do a good job
of figuring out you know oh you made a
mistake have the AI be able to figure
out what mistake you made and how to
explain how to explain what you did
wrong and how to think about it better
that seems like a thing AIS will be able
to do quite well and when it comes to
things like let's explain math let's say
and let's do it in a in a context that
this particular kid cares about
um you know if you you have you know the
math word problems where it talks about
you know so and so is is buying
marbles or something it's very very kind
of boring word problem but but you can
easily it's trivial to do this you say
make up a fifth grade math word problem
uh that's in the style of a fairy tale
talking about unicorns and uh you know
flying elephants or something
um and it'll happily make up such a
story and it kind of that particular
case is not bringing it to something
that's a practical uh resonance but
that's something where
um the uh you know you can kind of make
it much more uh much more resonant with
the person who has um
um uh who's doing it I know I know for
my kids at least one of them I'm
thinking of in particular who uh really
wouldn't learn math except in a very
specific context that uh that they
happen to be interested in and then they
were like oh yeah I can you know this is
interesting it's worthwhile but that's
something that one will be able to
personalize for everybody now in terms
of what one should learn I would say
that the the absolute number one one
thing to learn is kind of how to think
how to kind of think strategically about
things how to figure out things how to
how to learn is really a useful thing to
learn I think that a detailed kind of
skills learning will be less important I
think that very specialized kind of
drilling down into learning lists and
and kind of um is is is less relevant
because that drill down can be done much
more automatically but you need to know
you need to know enough about how to
understand things that when you are
doing one of those drill Downs with an
AI as an assistant
um that you can kind of tell what's
going on I think also it's important and
this is sort of uh you know you might
think oh when there are AIS around who
needs to learn any facts about anything
I think that's not correct I think that
what's important is to be able to think
broadly and to sort of Define things
strategically figure out sort of goals
and so on and that has to be anchored
with facts and those have to be sort of
mixed together in one's mind in a way
that is is that's sort of what the AIS
don't do because they're not sort of in
the human position of of of of of kind
of pulling together all the things that
we humans might care about
so I think the um learning how to think
link like a human in the ways that
humans think well
um and having a good grasp of kind of
the modes of thinking and so on that's a
really worthwhile thing so you know
being able to think computationally
maybe being able to think a little bit
mathematically being able to think
logically philosophically all those
kinds of things those are
those are really worthwhile things for
people to learn how to do and and not
just at a meta level because that's not
how we humans learn it's even it's
amusing to see that even in the case of
like Chachi BT when you prompt it you
give it some abstract statement of the
prompt and then you give it three
examples and those examples seem to be
very important in having it actually
carry out the thing that you said to
carry out even though it's going to
analogize those examples and be able to
generalize from those things but
similarly with us as humans I think
drilling down and actually learning
stuff in some level of precision and
detail is important and learning the
sort of broad range of facts but I think
you know doing the the kind of the
procedural skills uh of of can I follow
this procedure I think that's less
important because I think that's
something that is really very
automatable and and we'll all be making
use of that automation as you know for
example in my own case having built you
know well from language and Mathematica
and so on and and predecessor of over
the course of the last well what is it
40 44 years now
um you know there are a lot of things
which many people have done by hand I've
never done that I haven't done them by
hand but the majority of my life because
I've built automation that that does
them and uh I don't I in fact feel the
better for that because because those
things were automated I could do more of
them I could develop intuition around
how those kinds of things work and you
know knowing how to sort of do that
piece of math by hand is not really such
an important thing and uh you know I
think that's the that's kind of the the
direction it's it's like learn to think
and you know for example you know I was
kind of thinking about these sort of
exercises of how you can sort of think
about things and it's kind of kind of
the the question like you know here's a
fact
why is it true how you would you know
whether this is true even if you don't
know the facts behind it how would you
know how would you test whether such a
fact is true a good exercise or you know
given this area what's something what's
a question you might ask about this area
that's kind of the opposite of what a
lot of education is doing now where it's
like here's a question now go answer
that question it's like here's an area
now go ask a question that's a
reasonable and interesting question to
ask given this particular area
let's see
um all right I need to go in a minute
here but um
uh
um Elegance is asking
will the dog have the IQ to understand
us deeply that's the problem with AI we
might be like dogs in terms of
understanding AI we might not understand
it yeah well that's that's true I mean
it is a it will be the case just like
you know with Chad gbt do we understand
what's going on inside yeah we can
describe how it works and so on but do
we really understand it can we say if we
switch if we put the word please into
this prompt is it going what effect is
it going to have we have no idea we just
have to try it and see and I think that
you know what we will see happen in the
world is this kind of civilization of
the AIS where lots of things are
happening through AI in these through
these mechanisms where uh there's
there's you know all these bits running
around and we can't understand what's
happening we we but you know I think I I
mentioned this before but you know the
big analogy for that is nature the
natural world lots of things go on in
the natural world that we don't
understand we have some forms of
describing them through Natural Science
through our intuition through things we
come to expect you know we have we have
certain expectations what we can have
but lots of things in the natural world
we don't intrinsically understand and we
just have this way of interacting with
them we've learned to sort of exist
along with the um uh uh with the natural
world and so on and so so you know kind
of I think that's what it's going to
what it's going to feel like is you know
there's a there's the civilization of
the AIS and there will be experts just
like there are natural scientists today
will understand more than the than
everybody else perhaps about how some
aspect of the natural world works so
similarly there will be AI scientists
who understand Lots about how the AI
civilization works and occasionally
there will be sort of Interventional
things that can be done kind of just
like in the natural world they're
occasionally Interventional things that
can be done you know reduce the amount
of carbon dioxide by pulling it out with
a machine or do this or that or or you
know
you know put up a dam to prevent the
water coming into this particular place
or whatever else there there are
interventions we can make in the natural
world so similarly there will be
interventions we will be able to make in
the AI World
um I think the only thing that's a bit
funky right now is that we humans well
biology in general has sort of
co-evolved with the natural world for a
couple of billion years and so we've
gradually adapted to sort of the the how
the natural world works and you know we
know they're going to be forest fires so
there are all kinds of special seeds
that that come to life when there's been
a forest fire and you know that's just
sort of the way it works but you know
that there's a couple of billion years
of evolution that um uh were were used
to get to that point in the case of AI
it's coming pretty suddenly and we have
to be a little bit clever I would say to
uh to sort of do the right things in
this situation where we don't have a
couple of billion years to figure out
what to do and that's kind of a
challenge for um uh for our current time
is to figure out what the right things
to do are and I think it's a it's an
interesting topic maybe we'll cover that
one of these times I I'd love to have
actually a more General discussion with
people because I'm I'm really interested
in in these questions like uh sort of uh
how do we think about what
we should be kind of generally having
AIS aspire to doing what are some ways
of thinking about that that are
ultimately still you know we're still in
a humans in charge world
we may not you know it's uh I think as a
as a human I kind of uh would like to
think we'll stay in a humans in charge
World
um and uh you know now's our chance to
figure out what do we do in the kind of
humans in charge type world you know
when I say humans in charge world
obviously the natural world we're not in
charge of and there are plenty of things
about the natural world where things
just happen you know there are climate
fluctuations there are uh things you
know there are hurricanes there are uh
all sorts of um
all sorts of things that just happen in
the natural world over which we have no
Direct Control and so it's uh it we're
not really completely in the humans in
charge world in the small bubble of kind
of uh uh of sort of activities in which
we humans are used to doing then we've
made this bubble where we are sort of
the the you know where where it is a
humans in charge world where you know if
we're we're we're sitting in our houses
which are keeping us away from you know
the thunderstorms that are happening
outside so to speak and so we can do
things which are sort of of human
determined uh in a human-determined way
rather than just the rain is coming down
and there's nothing we can do about it
all right I should probably wrap up here
for now thank you for all sorts of
interesting questions and comments and I
look forward to doing this again uh
another time next week
thanks a lot bye for now